I mean this we have to start talking
about sacrifices for 1% lifes like if
you've got to make your dream if you
want to be in [ __ ] the to game video
game if you want to be friends with
LeBron and demilo if you want to be an
sneaker deal you need to eat some
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey guys I'm doing my
podcast with two very handsome and
accomplished gentlemen today I decided
not to do a scurvy in live because we're
gonna record this before two
ridiculously awesome announcement that
they're gonna drop at some point during
this interview that I think knowing my
audience a ridiculous amount of you are
going to watch and engage with and so
without further ado I'd love for you to
to introduce yourselves maybe share the
mic a little bit if you can and tell
everybody who's listening what you what
you do and what you're about and who you
are and then we'll start to chop cool
yes my name is Chris Brickley yeah
MBA trainer trainer Chris I don't know
how this happened I always loved how
like one second but I don't know but
this is how my life works the fact that
you're you were so ingrained in
basketball and your last name has brick
in it and of people that must be like
how that hasn't hit me until this moment
yeah the best [ __ ] that's funny I've
gotten you know you read the comments
people are we saying that stuff right oh
my husband's about is someone listening
to you well basketball you have brick in
your last name obviously the most
negative thing about a shot happens all
the time but yeah so I was I was a
director of player development the
Knicks for four seasons that kind of got
my foot in the door with the NBA stuff
and now I'd you know train bunch NBA
guys own a clothing line called
colorblind and Black Ops is umbrella
that we do the training under there's my
manager Alex Koblenz I work with a bunch
of
tre young Kevin Knox Chris you know we
focus generally on their digital side of
stuff but with Chris we do everything
off the court got it so what the players
are they're digital
you're not necessarily their certified
agent no they're doing the marketing so
what tre right for example as somebody
who's like super deep now into my number
one thing on earth right now like
literally I can't make people believe it
by the way let me hedge it here I do not
believe I believe old basketball cards
are ridiculously great long-term
investment Alijah one barkley rookies
way back I'm gonna loo come in here and
open the safe I want to show them my Lew
Alcindor rookie cards um but on some
short-term [ __ ] and I don't know when
the market called the next 18 to 24
months and then it might collapse but
for the next 18 to 24 months rookie
cards are the best fit what's that what
are those these are panini get the Lew
Alcindor reviewers look at me you're
looking at it yeah there's nothing but
cards in that safe Jackie Robinson
rookie card 1948 leaf well I mean for
you to write that's the real one the
real you've got the real is that yeah
that's
Kareem's [ __ ] rookie it's amazing
that was why your initial hustles with
cards that's right like I'm literally
going full like my current hustles are
sports cards and wine I'm literally
living my 1994 life again that's crazy
25th anniversary tour baby what anyway
so got it so you do them you do
marketing stuff for and you do marketing
for him that's awesome he's like changed
my life as far as actually you know what
back to like hey I want to make sure
people know about your show I don't want
to talk about basketball culture there's
a ton of general [ __ ] I want to talk
about but actually knowing how many
entrepreneurs are here so impersonal
brands and influencers you know hearing
somebody who have saying he changed my
life we hear nothing but horror stories
of
like I hired this [ __ ] person they
took 20% they did dog [ __ ] it [ __ ]
sucks
you just have changed my life take the
mic 100% you changed my lifestyle that's
for everybody out there who's got a
little something going followers little
Fame you know Netflix celebrity or
[ __ ] Instagram this and that and like
thinking about manager why did he change
your life everything was over the place
I thought I could I thought I could just
do my DMS and emails contact these
companies and yeah and so in like a year
he's gotten me you know the first
trainer ever to be have my you know real
sneaker deal up again be a player
sneaker deal I'm and in an NBA 2k I'm
the first trainer ever to have my own
character in 2k that's [ __ ] crazy so
Ike so basically everyone in the world
that plays a video game I'm the most
famous trainer you have to train with me
yes which is cool they're my tattoos on
there and that was a nightmare the
tattoos yes it's a huge thing the IP o
the artists are suing 2k it's like left
and right so they are like do this super
complex yeah this is where art this is
where people try to do like artists
tattoo artists out there
oh you I'm gonna say something right now
I haven't heard about this only because
I knew some stuff cover up the Hulu
thing with Damian Lillard
if artists are trying to sue for their
it's their art on people's body when
then it goes into games or movies and
stuff it's a really interesting thing if
you go down that route they're gonna
blur it out hmm
cool now what how'd you get put on in
the first place sex I think also there's
other issues because you know there's
people still on my [ __ ] take all my
content make money you know me people
run garyvee accounts on YouTube pre-roll
and make money on my [ __ ] do you know
how many people strip all my content set
up a separate YouTube account that they
own and run ads against my [ __ ] and make
money a lot you know who's the happiest
of it me I'm getting the exposure keep
the pennies I'll take the dollars yeah
right there that should be it right
there good yes oh he's done you up in a
red boat deal he's just got me all these
deals um dad as a full-time professional
I couldn't get myself you ironically as
a trainer and understands how many jump
shots one has to take to be good at it
on the business side try to do the [ __ ]
that US grub players think oh yeah well
I shoot sometimes and I should be good
yeah what doesn't happen it's the reps
for sure that's awesome so he's a he's
done and then you have a new train
facility just basically you know 360
forty fourth and third so I helped
design it
it's this beautiful state of our
basketball change is the [ __ ] happened
and why and when when all of a sudden
everyone just started talking about this
gym that the [ __ ] legit [ __ ]
players during the offseason we're funky
ass clothes like so much of culture
that's like a fashion show yeah like the
hoodie [ __ ] LeBaron's crazy like [ __ ]
hooked up shorts and [ __ ] like like
that's like like how the [ __ ] did that
happen what was that and for everybody
who's listening right now frame it up
because I think a lot of people know
about it because they've seen the clips
but they haven't made the association to
your world mm-hmm yeah how did it happen
and you have this gym in my in my mind I
just did it was doing these workouts you
know I've always been in the fashion
tattoos or whatever whatever the fashion
thing I'm always been in the music Chris
Brown was like one of my best friends
years ago and that opened their eyes
yeah yeah you can't like you guys were
friends as kids no I thought we from 24
to 28 I always liked someone we
connected I was with Melo training in LA
he just got out of jail and um we met at
a party and he's like yo it's the
workout so I worked him out he kind of
just loved it yeah and uh we became real
close and that's kind of how today I'm
so I wanted Travis Scott store taught
him how to shoot for like two months
during the winter that was crazy such a
[ __ ] similar life you and I just in
different skill sets in the same way
that all the thick people that I think
are the coolest want to come and get
a skill for me in business all the
people that you think are the coolest
want to get better basketball yeah it's
crazy it's gun yeah I think I want to
get better I am the worst jump shot of
anybody I know
no I'm effective with it but from a form
standpoint it's completely dismantled
thank you you did before you walked in
here I don't think so we need to do a
session oh no it's incredibly awkward
it's some some Shawn Marion [ __ ] it
looks ridiculous and goes in way more
than it should but nowhere close to
anything that's respectable we need to
do a session would you be down for it
okay we're going to I actually have been
thinking a lot about you know I've been
working out now for the last four years
and I'm pissed and I'm starting hit
fatigue I've gained some weight and I've
like lost a little my way and I think
it's just boredom of the thing and I'm
like maybe I need to fight like lately
I've been thinking about like maybe I
should fight like maybe I should work
out to actually fight like like you know
you know those will learn how to fight
right cuz like at this point with what's
going on my life that's probably a good
skill set whether it's a as you get more
Fame and known like something weird
could go down and somebody gets crazy
and B as you get more known you might
just want to challenge somebody else
that's cool and beat them up and have a
viral video like I just want to beat up
somebody like you know so like that
might be getting ya but I'm not scared
of losing I would probably be the most
excited if there was a clip of me
getting nuff knocked the [ __ ] out by
Dave East I'm like this guy I probably
when I wake up the next day I'd probably
be like you know this is at least eight
million views yes I could imagine when
you're not worried about losing you know
scared money you know when you're not
worried about losing that's what I love
about [ __ ] UFC fighters they all are
gonna lose it's a nature of the sport
yeah it's not like boxing where there's
enough padding where skill is like it's
just too raw anyway nonetheless so you
guys making prints yeah the question
yeah I don't know I just
New York City's helped New York City's
helped you know being obsessed with the
game has helped not caring about money
for the first eight years of trainings
helped being broken struck I mean you
know this about me mmm so I got to use
other examples besides me saying
we live in it tell the kids how much you
today with all that like 90% of my
audience wants to be doing what you're
doing
mmm tell them how much actually eating
[ __ ] for eight years for real for real
and explained your [ __ ] eating because
when you're not worried about money
you're eating [ __ ] mm-hmm and people
like you know people always like me like
it was easy for you Gary your dad gave
you a liquor son like you don't know my
story
I built my dad's business before him I
left at 34 do you think I would have
started vaynermedia at 34 years old in
somebody else's yeah no [ __ ]
conference room if I had all sorts of
money you know I built a business for
somebody else in the 34 by never paying
myself more than a hundred thousand I
had no money when I tell everybody be
patient it's easy I did it I was 34 and
had no money I made a video yesterday if
you're 26 I want to remind you that I
was ringing up people at a register in a
liquor store when I was your age tell me
about the eight years yeah [ __ ] it
actually kind of gives me on even like
talking about it because I don't want a
kid to see it and be like damn I don't
think I could yeah I was just dead broke
you know I had zero money I would do
workouts for free I would always Mike
McCown was always in the negative people
didn't think that dope said beer and MBA
guys you know I slept in the Ole Miss
practice facility with rats for a whole
year getting $1,000 for the whole season
you know I lived in New York and every
debt you could think of possible people
thought that everything was good cuz I'm
working on MBA guys but it wasn't a 0
grow up I grew up in New Hampshire so
right so the people from back home like
oh he went to the big city oh yeah
yeah and I think it's great I didn't
charge and be hey guys at first I just
wanted to get my why um I was worried
that off to bat why because I was
worried that if I was in a charged them
that they were gonna be like they
weren't gonna want to do it I don't know
what I don't know why I like period
Bowie for everybody who's listening and
saying this is [ __ ] you tell like
some people got mad at me recently
you're telling everybody do something
for free I'm like I'm not talking about
you do anything I'm telling everybody
one of the ways to get in you're looking
at two people who did things for free
that got in you want to charge charge
you think some noble act is being put on
you of like
like people are mad like you're
undermining the price of something I'm
like no not the market is the market you
go to the [ __ ] do you think I am you
think my little point of view in the
world impacts designers and artists and
trainers get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah I'm giving you one of the ways in
subway nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are
they don't want to pay you facts facts
yeah I clearly would go months literally
in ramen noodles in the subway every
single meal easy as [ __ ] to do that at
20 like the way you're saying it right
now and everybody's like you said don't
I don't think anybody that's easier in
twenties sometimes but like it's not the
worse than your twenties no like if
you've got to make your dream if you
want to be in [ __ ] the two game video
game if you want to be friends with
LeBron and demilo if you want to be an
sneaker deal you need to eat some
[ __ ] [ __ ] in your 20s which oh by
the way you eat anyway hmm you'd much
rather eat [ __ ] [ __ ] in your 20s to
live the life you're living now than to
waste it like do me people complain and
are living in a studio apartment in
Bushwick and buying $5 coffees you're
making the wrong [ __ ] decision you
don't want it that bad you're not
willing to sacrifice you want to make
pretend you're winning along the way
there are a few times I'd be a poet
iPlayer would fly me out say we'd be in
Miami and we have to meet at University
of Miami Jim and I would have to take
over to meet the player and that that
override who are you an executive yeah
and then I didn't have a way to get back
you know facts life happened numerous
time stuff like that so how'd you get
back I would have to make up a story
with the MBA guy I didn't want them beep
no when I was broke either yeah so I'd
have to be like yo um my thing I would
say my uber account was like because my
rate I would lie about my rating I
couldn't get over Q you know that star
rating I need you dog
yeah cuz I did that man I uh oh yeah you
actually do have it no sir not a nice
guy right no I'm kidding no but uh your
reading is through the roof by the way
cuz I'm all charming and [ __ ] in the
back plus I was like first
that's dope we're talking about saying
actually actually where's AJ [ __ ] right
there have you ever seen this this is
the one of the great mistakes of my
career Travis comes to New York and he's
like yo Gary I need you to take the
first goober in New York cuz I got a
test to service and I'm like I gotta go
on this client call I'm like yo AJ take
it that is an email from uber emailing
AJ thanking him for being the first ever
person to take an uber in that's wild
New York how crazy is that email yes
what's a what's a safer dick podcast
hey AJ I wanted to say thanks for being
our first ever uber rider in New York
guys do you know lucky the world is that
AJ was the first Super Rider and I
wasn't cuz AJ's super humble and quiet
doesn't talk about [ __ ] if that was me I
would this story would have been told
today for the 19 mm time this week you
also got a credit says for 10 bucks I
know I might have to actually post that
he's a big ol bird a there's a very
interesting day for me Wow yes I mean I
lost I lost out on lots but I made lots
nobody's crying for me today this is Wow
so yes so that's that was your life when
did you when did it turn to something a
little more sustainable you got the job
of the Knicks yeah a little bit yeah for
sure that helped my first year at the
next I was an intern so they were they
don't pay anything I was so I actually
had to live with the that is funny I've
never spoken said this [ __ ] scoops uh
yeah so I live with the girl she was
like my girlfriend but I really didn't
really like it like that I was just
living with their sorry to have a spot
to live um I was in Jersey yeah so human
does a lot of that going on a whole year
and is just up because I just wanted to
be in basketball on to work so bad that
I would sacrifice my personal life of
spending time with her whoo and I didn't
even really love her maybe she might
have thought I did and then the next
year I got a promotion and
actually broke up but there's [ __ ] up
listen everybody's listening you know
what's funny
they think it's [ __ ] up but if you
really talk real [ __ ] and humans don't
talk real [ __ ] people make trades bro
people make trades she might hear this
and instead of what everybody thinks
like all her feelings are she like I
[ __ ] them that's real that's real talk
guys everyone's like this sounds like
stunts I'm obviously using the exposed
extreme way to say it but she's like
maybe she loved that year hmm maybe
that's the best year I don't know maybe
it's not maybe she's pissed
I don't know but humans make trades and
humans make sacrifices and we don't talk
truth in our society we don't talk about
sex in our society we don't talk about
money in our society you know not for
sure it's just the truth
you could everybody listening you could
judge all three girlfriends I had in my
20s were there because I didn't want to
be lonely because I was working from
9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. every [ __ ] day
I wasn't dating I didn't go I worked
every Friday and Saturday night from 22
to 28 of my entire [ __ ] life till
9:00 to 10:00 p.m. and was tired after
working 15 hours in a retail store on my
feet on the floor so now at 43 can be
like right those girlfriends were a
utility for an enablement for what I
wanted I was nice to them
we had good relationships yeah there's
some wonder Punk that they could walk
around and say they put my girlfriend
for a couple years now it's not making
it better for them and more importantly
not even like that like LOI like
whatever like more that it was a it was
a fine time like everybody's trying to
do the best they can and maybe I didn't
even I didn't fully realize I was doing
that mm-hm it's subconscious yes you
that's true right right looks like it's
your master plan was you know like you
know what I mean yeah you realize it
later mm-hmm so for everybody who's
judging seven minutes ago [ __ ] you look
at your own [ __ ] actions Thanks
yes the Knicks
um I guess just recently just within the
past year so I could tell I told my dad
you know you get retire you know that
could really take care of I could start
doing stuff with money and yes a long
time people it didn't take that long
let's again yeah I'm going very real
here there's something about us together
at this moment like I'm going to a lot
of real places no it did not take very
long sounds like it was about eight or
nine ten years when you live a hundred
[ __ ] years that's not a big
percentage of your life if you actually
told people to eat [ __ ] for nine years
and it will highly likely result in a
lot more of what you're trying to
achieve not maybe everything that you
dreamed up and [ __ ] yachts and [ __ ]
but a lot more than if you spent nine
years being half pregnant living in the
studio by yourself instead of with a
roommate drinking a four dollar Blue
Bottle coffee in Bushwick instead of
making Maxwell House [ __ ] I mean
this we have to start talking about
sacrifices for 1% lifes you want to
retire papa you have to drink [ __ ]
there's nobody retiring there Papa
starting at zero in nine years that
drinks $4 coffee in Bushwick and that's
what I see from everybody everybody's
complaining and hard takes forever I'm
like you're wasting money on dumb [ __ ]
you're not sacrificing for your actual
dream you want it to be easy all along
the way you still think it's [ __ ]
high school and your parents are taking
care of you hmm
soft you guys are [ __ ] soft well a $4
coffee is like the easiest thing to cut
out right I mean when and ready for this
actually it's a great opportunity has
been meaning to clarify this I don't
think people who drink $4 coffee or soft
if they don't complain almost all my
advice actually an exciting advice
because I actually don't think I'm
putting out advice I think I'm putting
out context of information that you need
to look at and decide what it means for
you that's my intent mm-hmm but the one
clarification just for everybody
listening is I don't think you're soft
if you drink $4 coffee I think you're
soft if you complain about your life and
drink $4 coffee if you complain that
your start you can't raise money for
your startup cool save your money and
you can start your own startup I
four dollar coffee but I'm not
complaining out here yeah so I don't
think it took long bro and so now as you
know how old are you 32 I'm all older
than you think
no you're not and I think because I can
do basic math of like you being out of
school in eight years like here's what I
think I think I wish a lot more people
are really listening and paying
attention because I think 99% of the
world would eat [ __ ] for the first 10
years of the professional life to get
the 32 to be in a position to be doing
what they want lucrative ly but they're
confused because they didn't want to put
in any days of sacrifice let alone three
thousand six hundred fifty of them mmm
that's real that's it that's actually my
current thesis and the whole [ __ ]
thing
lack of sacrifice lack of sacrifice for
the ambition that's coming out of your
mouth hmm I don't want anybody to be
stressed I don't want any be upset I
just want if you're telling me that you
want to be the most famous basketball
trainer in the world
that's rats in the gym that's walking
back cuz you can't get an uber
that's not kinda sorta that's not
spending $4,000 on tickets on Coachella
I have no problem with Coachella
I've problem with you talkin that [ __ ]
and not living it mm-hmm
I didn't say anything for the first 15
years of my life to anybody forget about
social media people like well you didn't
have social me I'm like I didn't talk to
anybody go talk to my high school
friends go talk to my college friends I
didn't even talk that's real Israel cool
tonight are 32 and now [ __ ] changes
right yeah now you got to recalibrate
for sure you actually done the
ridiculous stream that you thought for
yourself yeah but I still want that
still so much more in my mind I'm still
trying to still wake up every morning
like I'm I you know I'm not fulfilling I
believe that instead of bigger and
better right a bigger stinker deal a
bigger instead a bigger better is there
anything completely left field that you
want to accomplish not a no no just keep
this do what I'm doing and just keep it
going
I get it yeah but yeah you're right sir
no it's the funny thing I think a lot
about that lately for myself go ahead
push it oh yes I'll buy the first
trainer ever to make it being inducted
into the Basketball of Fame except dad's
coaches there's talk about the
Basketball Hall of Fame
yeah why is it such [ __ ] I know this
is your dream and you're gonna get it
I'll tell you why I gotta get why is it
[ __ ] up why is it to not have enough
rigor you know this is what every fans
problem is with the Hall of Fame right
why is it so soft just talking about the
basketball yeah cuz the other sports are
good yeah that's true
no this is you have a hot take on this
cuz I'm [ __ ] pissed that listen I
think Ben Wallace is a [ __ ] gangster
like is he in the oven you see what I'm
saying
he's about to be and oakes not I don't
know I get started like like listen he
manages Oakley to Oakley is in the
cultural Hall of Fame facts do you know
I can't like all clearly all the way and
I [ __ ] love him I love him like all
time but I can't love him all the way
why cuz he's friends with Jordan and I
can't get it out of my system
I could never fully go there I'm I'm in
a very weird spot as a die-hard nineties
Knicks fan with Charles Oakley because I
love him with all my heart I probably
used him to feel tough in high school
mmm like he's all that he's been to the
office couple years ago I love him as a
dude I [ __ ] love everything about him
but I can't [ __ ] with him all the way
that's cuz he's friends with Jordan he's
not friends with Jordan he's [ __ ]
Jordan's guy I don't give a [ __ ] I hate
Jordan he's right there use your hands
guy like yeah but not like hey I'm
friends like what that didn't impact
anything no no I I definitely I never
felt that I'm just talking life he's a
die-hard Knick fan too yeah you know or
once thought that that would be a reason
why because he was friends never me too
me too me too
especially now all these [ __ ] all
your boys all of friends I still don't
like I hate when people like oh they're
all friends now I'm like [ __ ] ah
I I'm friends like I've punched my
brother in the face on a basketball
court
mm-hmm I like did something sweet you
know my own clothes line me I'll do
anything on the court so I don't think
friendship matters I'm talking just
I'm pissed about it anyway nonetheless I
really am I still can't deal with it
god it's unbelievable how much I don't
respect Knick fans that have any love
towards Jordan I don't think you can be
in your 40s I think it could be
youngsters how old are you 34
you might just be young and I think
you're young and I would say you're like
if you're over 40 and I know by the way
I know I'm on o island all but like this
is an island of one I've never worn a
pair of Jordans ever I hate a man I
really do you wear Nikes yeah I do
I'm where Mike a Swiss but I wear Nikes
but I just I really dislike a man I
really really dislike a man I really if
I knew him personally like that's the
one thing I've learned as my life has
changed like oh this sucks now I know
these guys and now I can't hate them the
way I like wanna hate them mm-hmm you
know like I'm scared to meet Paul Pierce
cuz I loved hating Paul Pierce like this
week's been the best week mm-hmm
Paul Pierce getting [ __ ] on is the best
but I'm sure Paul's like a good do I
actually like a lot about what I know
about Paul like rug like there's a
question for you good what's your take
on when you when you because this
happened a few times you go your whole
life you like love someone look up to
someone it could be any music or
whatever and when you really get to know
me you're like let down you're like zero
expectation of others mm-hmm you will
never Chris you'll never meet a happier
[ __ ] on earth than me for one core
reason I have zero expectations of human
beings mmm nobody has ever let me down I
never gave him a chance
that's real I don't have expectations my
employees don't let me down I'm paying
them no craziness that is that is now
that's a weakness as a manager because
it creates entitlement and I've had to
learn that over the last 25 years I've
gotten better but it's crazy I've never
been I knew where you're going with the
question and usually cut off what I know
the question is I'm trying to train
myself now it's a great question and
it's [ __ ] man you want to talk about
something I'd love to teach kids don't
expect just because somebody can drop 50
to a night you think they're a nice
person
just because somebody's got a fat booty
on the inner you think there's
sweetheart like me don't have
expectations for sure
right on the flip side my favorite thing
on life I was like complex history doing
that sneaker show and the kid like was
really pumped that I was nice
you saw that I love it on the flip on
the flip I love over-delivering when
people meet me in the wild mm-hmm yes
sir I was out and about like like that
funny way to put it that's real that was
funny yeah
say what no I just because for a number
of years I'm big on night walks so I get
one in the morning I walk a few miles
and it's just nice my mental and I'm so
I used to do it anymore cuz you know a
little more no I mean I might add ah
now when I do the walks people would be
I prickly and so normally when my mind
is in like I'm like a weird state if you
catch me at 1:30 and I'm in my walk and
you say Brickley like I might look at
you kind of crazy cuz not because of you
looking at me because you're that deep I
got so I want an Instagram and it got to
the point where I feel like I was like
freaking people out I pause I was like
you know half joking half not like you
seem in the street in the middle of the
night and I looked at you like a ghost
like I apologize and as I'm typing it
someone it comes up to me and I put it
on the camera thing but I yeah so yeah I
get it you know what this is gonna end
up with you're gonna you're gonna
replace that with safer places my places
are the bathroom the shower and
airplanes where I do that the only
places where I know I can go into that
place are the places where nobody can
touch me that's real mm-hmm
like it's unbelievable what the
chemicals in my body do when I go into
the bathroom when I go into a shower or
when a plane takes off and nobody's
boarding anymore and I'm in my spot it
is unbelievably important to the
operating system of Who I am right now
that's real no because I [ __ ] hate
the gym
really like like this is like you know
so much of my advice now about like what
to do in life is predicated on me being
a terrible student and hating the gym
for everybody who's listening right on
the hates their job like I understand I
don't understand hating your job cuz
that was my great fortune of being an
entrepreneur but I understand the
process of disliking something that you
have to do you know mm-hmm well I don't
this is such a good show what uh you got
you have something big coming out don't
ya actually right Hillshire so yeah I
got a show on ESPN
he's been network called declared it's
not me getting of MBA prospects ready
for the NBA Draft
so mmm do on court off court you know
get him ready from a skill standpoint um
I'm ready mentally so much mental work
do you like how much do you think from
your perspective that you're like a nail
salon or a haircut like I love nails
what is it called and uh do you know
manicures but there was something else
remember they had a different room
technician you're on fire bro yeah
doesn't doesn't talk for [ __ ] on sonny's
really [ __ ] you're near zone bro
I love hairdressers and like you know
you know manicurists and just like
trainers and like cuz there's so much
there your therapist a lot of time
everything facts that's everything it's
it's you know obviously I need to know
what I'm doing we get in the court but
do you know we're gonna form but you're
also like talking through there girl
trouble yes you know personal uh
anything you could think of after a bad
game again no if I would the girlfriend
you know I mean you tell me sort of when
we were hanging once of like being up
super late cuz you got to watch the tape
of a West Coast game and you're [ __ ]
hit them but they and the some of these
[ __ ] maniacs which I love about them
because that's why they're winners and
want to [ __ ] talk at 2:37 yeah like
in the morning of like why you know why
you know why did they go three for 18
from the floor and if I don't respond I
dropped the ball they won't I could lose
the trust who's the best defender in
basketball right now in your opinion
Kawhi Leonard who's the next best give
me an unusual one cuz I know you watch a
lot more [ __ ] than
other people yep give me up give me a
one that's not exactly Beverly that's
easy
ah you got anything that's there were
the last couple years because I meet you
I know you might not Tony Allen best too
easy
oh I was amazing yeah the great it was
amazing
give me somebody that's like like I know
you might not be watching film - subject
being empathetic to all the things that
are going on your world give me one of
the last five to seven years that you
think it was like that you were like
geez you know what this [ __ ] guy
stuff that you just don't hear getting
headlights good all three of those guys
I know as a casual I mean my football
knowledge is much deeper my basketball
knowledge well I guess this could be oh
you the name is big but he doesn't get
the credit I actually think the best
on-ball defender in the NBA over the
past five years is Kevin Durant which no
one would think that but I fully
understand that because he's seven feet
tall legs and he moves like a guard so
he can guard a point guard but then he
can guard a 5-man cuz he's so long I
think people talk about that Steven
Naismith doesn't talk about that well
that doesn't get the you know that's not
what people want to talk about how good
of a defender I know like at this point
and he's still a baby
that you know there's less excitement
for him but like like Frank on the Nick
yes super defender
yeah cool I'm happy you know it's funny
I the Knicks have been so bad for so
long and my career took off like my
career I worked all the time like not
took off I was about to say that since I
was 22 I've been basically even that
great night 98 run I didn't fully like I
was just working mmm so it was on the
radio in the liquor store I think it was
hard like it wasn't 94 like and football
is easy for me with the Jets cuz it's
Sunday so I missed nothing
mmm but basketball even next year when
the gardens going to be rocking backs
I'm gonna be struggling to like really
be in it so but the last year or two you
know obviously we moved to Hudson Yards
here so I'm like got the crazy Knicks
seats and I'm trying to do more and and
just like look sports cards I mean these
deer and foxes I would have known the
deer and fox four years ago in the
league the way I do now cuz the cards
because this and I know the Knicks are
coming so like my basketball game has
changed dramatically of like being on it
in the last 18 months and the players
look up to
yeah you're right and that's been really
cool so really like I test I'm like
watching and I'm like man Frank could be
just because I remember how good of a
defender Derek Harper was like there was
a time when I knew everything and so
like that's what went through my mind
like oh [ __ ] he's like a New Age Derek
Harper mm-hmm it's guilty that I know
you can't stay healthy right can't stay
healthy and offensively he just he's
living it yeah he is a kid that needs to
get his confidence up yeah yeah he's
really young he's really young
defensively though he would take on John
Collins as a player yes he's very good
actually so I actually make a list when
the seasons done and I do like five ten
guys that I'm like I want to try and I
gotta train with him and he's on notice
so he's um he's what's that yeah a job
he's on my list of sports card
investment that's that was the most
loaded [ __ ] question like shut drop
five g's I'm John Collins rookie cards
we sue brick know this is why this is
such a great game John Collins rookie
cards a couple bucks but it could be 450
bucks if I miss right about where I
think his game I go how much is some of
those well know that we brought out
those were the the cream rookies are
8,000 a piece graded but like these
Darren Fox ungraded are four bucks I
think so like and then you can get
created like that's how they go in these
cases like these these these Luka
rookies oh that's gonna kill this uh
that's Kevin McHale look at this look
Luka rookie mm-hmm - put him in those
cases at cost eight bucks that Luka
rookies now 75 I bought I was telling
everybody on social media only 30 days
ago to buy him they were 40 Wow
it's an interesting game because I have
to be careful because I have to really
really start doing a better job context
and I think there's a really hot market
for the next two years I think people
should buy and sell new stuff like the
game used you mean like like memorabilia
that's not my game cuz there's no scale
like I I'm gonna buy I bought a hundred
eighty-seven Yanis rookie cards in
October for 150 apiece now there's 550
and for all the sneaker hustler kids
I think there's money to me like I think
there's a great two three-year run here
for these kids while it's two three
years what's happening with the cards I
don't know what if the economy collapses
the first thing that goes our cards just
like $4 coffee
you know cards I mean nobody on earth
will buy them when you're scared of my
money so they go so supply and demand I
think the man's about to build up but
there's a lot of these cards so if the
man it's like in 90s the whole collapse
market of the cards that's why it
happened and you got to be right lonzo's
have gone down dramatically in the last
two years so we could be sitting here 24
months ago I can be talking heavy about
this Lonzo thing kids could go out and
buy meth I don't know what it was but
let's say 75 and now two years later
than 25 mmm so - it was crazy
you know it's what do you think about
him I actually think he's really good
actually i think i yeah i actually
weirdly think he like i actually that's
that's actually probably the guy i'm
most debating to go all-in on cuz i
think he's super low right now and
everybody's mine and I'm like here's my
thing actually this is actually crazy
why this is segwang and talk to me about
the what is your macro take on people
like Ben Simmons and Lonzo and people
who like how much you would jump cannon
and I don't want to put you on blast
like those guys don't sure you'll be
able to talk about it how much better
can a human get like what's the great
story in the last decade of somebody
changing their form or becoming a
ridiculously better jump shooter that's
a great question
yeah I mean it's anything Ben Simmons
isn't gonna just uh all of a sudden be a
knockdown shooter it's not gonna happen
I think taking away from but he can do
what LeBron and Jordan did in their
careers which is exponentially get
better for sure he can keep getting
better in his shock and keep getting
better too
but what's scary is if he [ __ ] if he
got a solid jump shot for sure he would
become unbearable be a beast he's a
beast to begin with yes he would be it
at next for sure I really like him a lot
too was like a kid like I think man I
really want him to develop it well I
don't actually just [ __ ] the Sixers but
he would be really like that was for you
Ruben
you'll never convert me bro I'm a Knicks
fan mm-hmm [ __ ] the Sixers
and I'm like I love JJ like I love Ben I
love Tobias is the best as humans but
[ __ ] them the grid about that city's
dope doe this to divide to a new watch
how does take us fillies the best city
it's dope it's a good girl
yeah like New York's the best city in
the world but I wish New York felt like
Philly Philly's a little rugged like New
York's become too Manhattan's too rich
it's super rich around here you go to a
game at the garden and it's kind of like
yes fancy you know what he's walking the
streets of those one Am's
he wouldn't have done that 30 years ago
no matter how sad a toughy is like New
York soft true I walk around comfortable
and cozy in New York now 1978 be scared
fuckless out here you really has that
people I were like [ __ ] facts know who's
who's the most who's the top I want to
finish this thought because I want to
get this I know we have to probably wrap
up because I got family stuff the show
drops the show on ESPN my goal is to
change these kids lives in a sense of
the after this year's series when the
New York Knicks have the 9th to the NBA
Draft they could pick player a or player
B but player a was real quick now you're
making an amazing point I'll let you do
it again but the the shivers in my body
that just happened when you said Knicks
have the 9th pick like if the Knicks
don't have other 25 he's talking about I
got it but then you know if that happens
- shivers we should be really in a place
where 2024 should be good season like
I'm expecting like Pat Ewing is gonna be
there mmm like if this is to me you know
it's ironic I like the first three
players quite a bit I do think it's that
cut like I'm gonna buy a lot of
basketball cards this season cuz I think
it reminds me a little bit of measure
you know Darko was the one that didn't
work out but that rest that class got
crazy with Bosh and Wade and LeBron and
Melo
that was that was crazy class these
first three feel really JIT mm-hmm with
news Barrett
you know Barrett's game reminds me of a
lot
and I want to ask somebody more educated
than me and just like in a weird way
Michael Beasley RG Barrett's game
reminds me a lot of Michael Beasley like
at this time in their careers and
obviously thinks about yeah I don't know
mindsets and those work no no you see
I'm going like the guard version of
Beasley for sure kind of like that yeah
it's kind of interesting he's definitely
thinking to be consensus perfect I would
yeah the thing it's still like a you
know whether the sons get it and they
need a point guard or whatever but just
have a talent you gave me the you be
three what do you want to wrap up with
everything that we discover anything
interesting there's been great you gonna
start collecting basketball cards yeah
do it on a very sir snow I kind of want
you to I really think there's something
brewing
is it only panini and like panini has
the IP for basketball tops for baseball
panini for football yeah baseball is
like the place where you can make early
baseball cuz you can get kids four years
away you can get crazy you can buy kids
for a $0.50 that go for fifty bucks if
you get Fernando Tati's jr. the
basketball miner the basket yeah they're
in the yes they sell them as might early
carts basketball though is culture my
hot take complete thesis my entire point
of view on this is sneaker kids are
gonna realize that's great that you want
to get the Travis Scott Jordans but
you're gonna get one pair and you'll
make your money but if you're right
about Darren Fox you can go on eBay and
buy up a thousand of them for four bucks
and then when he pops and they're [ __ ]
39 let's starts adding up and it's
liquid it's even it's liquid as [ __ ] its
eBay you go to ebay right out like its
liquid as [ __ ] you go to completed items
like what sells what doesn't at what
price if though it's the Moke listen
I've loved cards is forever for me to
now be talking about them I listen I'm
starting to build a good enough track
record I don't talk about [ __ ] for fun I
don't like to show videos like I did
this morning about me passing on uber I
like to show the [ __ ] where I'm like you
should buy Amazon and it explodes
basketball cards are gonna go through
the [ __ ] roof for the next two years
no Beckett is actually you know what
Beckett is now
it's a grating company the price guide
is eBay right now bro if you really know
basketball like if you know if you know
the dude from Toronto SEC what's a
necessity yes zackham if you know see a
curbs gonna pop last year which people
did and you bought them last year
compared to this year you made a
fuckload if you know the [ __ ] kid and
Sacramento shot gold it was his name
yeah alexander's yeah yeah I was just
talking to him actually yeah if you know
he's gonna pop next cuz he looks like he
could be one of the guys John Collins
could be one of the guys sure like if
you up yeah a finite time right like
word peaks and then well I mean you
wanna hear something crazy I bought
those 180g honest rookies stick with
this real quick and I sold I sold ten of
them to just like cuz I was like hey I
bought these for a hundred eighty I'm
some 10 of them for 300 a month ago and
now they're 550 like the markets hot yes
there's a finite time there's by the way
there's a no-brainer he could have a
good work year playing it for a couple
years and like like that cut those cards
you have them there
those are iconic I'm saying I'm talking
to like a buying whole this is like a
trade this is well it's a buy and hold
if they become caught you know Kairi
like like like like like you it become
it depends on how creative but it this
is what's great its merit-based it
depends on how good they become like it
just like their game you stuff like
their value is one they're actually
starts get in this mode and like heavily
into the game you stuff yeah and the
value of buying like a Damian Lillard
now right in his game used Portland
trailers
what is it gonna be worth ten years from
now is probably not gonna be what it's
worth now ready for this
that's exactly right here's how it works
you have to go top 1% if you're holding
forever what am i buying is LeBron
rookies I'm buying LeBron rookies for
1,100 I'm buying Kobe rookies for 1,100
I'm buying all time stuff and then I'm
speculating on under Pro Delille 'red
actually to me is still a speculation
because if he has one more contract
that's crazy not in Portland gets on a
super team and wins a championship he's
under priced right
right like I'm trying to figure out if
kimba or kairi's coming to New York and
which rookie card I want to buy for the
New York bump I'm not buying
Leonard rookie cards cuz I think he's
too not culture and no matter how great
of a player is it's not gonna be supply
and demand enough because people don't
[ __ ] with him culturally enough and
there's nothing wrong with that that's
amazing he's an awesome dude I love how
he leans into that and lays like
self-deprecating I by Luca like crazy
because because he's white and if he's
Larry Bird there'll be a mark I think
this is just very basic [ __ ] you're
right I know I'm trying to help kids
make some money out here so pay
attention they can be
I have no stake in panini yeah I I
you'll appreciate this I the number one
thing that would make me a ton of money
right now is if Pinterest went crazy on
the stock market how many times do you
think I've mentioned the word Pinterest
in my content in the last few years
how many goose [ __ ] egg the number
one currency in my life is being
historically correct not any of the
deals I'm in that's deep it's it's it's
it makes sense right don't sell out I've
made money I don't need to like like
Vito
I'd love to have a piece of panini I'm
trying to do [ __ ] in sports card world
cuz I love it
here's why in 24 months I'm gonna be not
the only person talking about it in 24
like I can't wait to be courtside
opening night Durant
Kyrie [ __ ] the holes I on and I'm
gonna have like I'm know in my pockets
bring 50 brookie cards and take a selfie
courtside with all the cards if you like
what I'm making a prediction the way
kids now rich the kid puts [ __ ] a
stack of cash to his ear I'm making a
prediction right now in 24 months people
can be flexing holding [ __ ] luca's
like this
[Music]
it's a prediction buy some cards I
guarantee you he's gonna do it now do I
kit in I'm just curious like what are we
gotta go see you
[Music]